et maintenant j'accueille
jean d'ormesson et la musique
ah ah
parce dit jean d'ormesson joël jeu 10 en
or me sens une connerie le comte jean
bruneau vladimir françois de paule
lefebvre d'ormesson génial jean
d'ormesson vous voulez toujours dans
votre vieux coupé mercedes
oui lanvin fait toujours pour vous
spécialement son eau de lanvin oui voilà
c'est toujours dans le sens est ouest
jean d'ormesson j'adore jean d'ormesson
je le dis franchement et tout de suite
vous incarnez pour moi une espèce de
france est en voie de disparition
malheureusement je crains d'être
moi-même bientôt en voie de disparition
parlez pas de malheur non mais j'ai
connu toutes les formes de déchéance y
compris le succès c'est pas une belle
phrase les honneurs je les méprise mais
je ne déteste pas forcément ce que je
méprise
voilà c'est du jean d'ormesson c'est un
peu comme la pâte ya une phrase pas ce
qui allait tout avoir pour pouvoir tout
maîtriser ces kiss et barrès ou péguy ou
un truc comme ça non maresches barrès
alors le public sait comment on fait un
publié chez robert laffont
un livre qui s'appelle voilier
commandant ce mets blessures
à laval c'est bien à senna asselah et
c'est la version chic sa version noble
bien alors entrer dans la danse
ça vient d'une chanson entrer dans la
danse voyez comment danse chante et
danse et embrassez qui vous voudrez
cette espèce de qui était déjà tout de
suite dès le titre espèce de fraîcheur
alors vous vous refusez à une époque où
tout le monde est dans l'accablement où
elle détient une époque le bonheur est
mal vu vous refusez tout ça mais jérémy
a d'abord refusé
écoutez je pense que si j'occupe une
place peut-être ta part enfin c'est pas
dur à mon talent mais peut-être parce
que j'essaye de donner un peu de bonheur
aux gens qui me voient là alors on sait
bien que on sait bien que la vie n'est
pas gay tous les jours je crois que
puisque vous avez la bonté de citer les
phrases de moi je crois que j'ai dit
quelque part que la vie était il fait en
larmes et ce livre là aussi c'est une
fête en larmes quand on lit le bouquin
on sent que vous amusez beaucoup à
dépeindre des personnages à raconter des
destins imaginer des intrigues on sent
un vrai plaisir d'écriture est au centre
du dispositif votre obsession pour le
temps finalement c'est un peu le
personnage qui revient dans tous vos
livres
d'abord est-ce que c'est un plaisir
d'écrire je dirais que c'est très
difficile
je dirais que c'est à la fois un bonheur
et une souffrance où il ya des pages que
j'ai recommencé 18 fois ah oui absolu
vous êtes très bien renseignés ou oui
c'est vrai je crois que ce qu'est le
plus difficile c'est de donner
l'impression de facilité est alors sur
l'autre point vous avez absolument
raison je pense que le personnage
principal lui vivre c'est le temps lui
c'est le temps qui passe qui m'a
toujours un peu obsédé par le seul gérer
un prédécesseur s'appelait prou ce que
c'est et occupait beaucoup aussi
est ce que c'est le temps qui passe le
nous qui passons peut-être que le temps
est immobile et c'est nous qui passons
oui non pas le temps malade mais nous
nous en allons d'ailleurs vous avez
changé de coiffure
alors que vous en penser les gens
pendant deux choses sérieuses
comment vous plaît aussi c'est un vrai
succès
en ce moment la clé par exemple ça fait
moins jean pierre foucault avec les
jouets qu'ils veulent alors vous mêlez
très bien la grande et la petite
histoire existe créer un roman total est
ce qu est une ambition tout à fait
louable et très moderne en même temps
vous savez il ya un film dont
quelques-uns d'entre vous ont vu qui
s'appelle la comtesse aux pieds nus
ouais alors au début il ya à vagues à
l'enterrement on bosse ici
et puis on ferait beau gars qui est là
et il revoit tout ce qui s'est passé
alors le lu le livre en un mot se passe
en trois heures dans un cimetière et à
propos de tous les gens qui passent en
même temps on part en chine en amérique
du sud en inde et le siècle antique
voilà ça commence par un enterrement on
enterre romain qu'on pourrait résumer en
disant qu'il vivait avec talent c'est un
ami du narrateur qui le grand
ordonnateur de ses funérailles et une
amitié finalement comme celle qui lie
deux personnes qui ont aimé la même
femme puisque tous les deux le narrateur
et celui commentaire oui mais marina des
belles séances à patmos je vais vous
dire ce livre est aussi c'est aussi une
histoire d'amour ouais et alors j'avais
écrit janice à un livre qui s'appelle
vent du soir où il y avait quatre soeurs
et là il y a permis de faire une mère et
une fille ouais et alors autant le 7 mai
elle ses deux filles vont il ya des
hommes qui tourne alors vers la mer ces
mecs réunion qu'on appelle la reine
margot donc est une collectionneuse de
marie damman et parler ses amants elle a
eu lui qui du cha no
le chef de la mafia new yorkaise et si
lui qui a organisé en partie le
débarquement américain en sicile du fond
de sa prison et ses les aventures
formulation est alors le piano actu est
naturellement comme ça se passe il a tué
son prédécesseur mais son prédécesseur
était italien aussi et pour le tuer on
disait les ceux qui voulaient le tuer
luciano ce disais c'est pas possible de
prendre des gangsters italien parce
qu'il connaît tous les dangers
mais on a pensé aux gangsters juifs
qu'ils connaissaient pas mais alors il
ya une autre difficulté c'est que le
meurtre avait été fixé un saint denis
parce que le samedi les gens étaient en
week end et les lagarde était moins
sérieux mais les gangsters juifs ont dit
le jour de sa mort n'ont rien à faire
qu'on tue pas le jour du shabbat
alors on a dû changer la date on l'a
fait à mercredi ça s'est bien passé
la fille c'est marina dont qui a été
mais effectivement à la fois par nature
et par romain celui commentaires ya
béchir donc un musulman qui fait la
guerre dans la wehrmacht et dont hitler
empreinte larmes pour celui-ci alors là
tout est vrai aussi il devrait il clair
c'est vraiment suicidé avec un valter
7,65 je crois alors vous dire que béchir
le noir c'est bon là peut-être qu'un
tout petit coup de pouce alors tout le
xxème siècle qui passe à travers des
souvenirs croiser des différents
personnages
vous m'avez dit dans tout le monde en
parle finalement le 20e siècle a eu à
choisir vous souvenez de ça entre deux
tragédies entre deux monstres le nazisme
et le stalinisme
est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement s'en
était débarrassé est ce qu'aujourd'hui à
lourdes du 21e siècle on voit pas
arriver encore un totalitarisme c'est
non pas encore une fois le fait d'être
musulman mais le fait d'être
fondamentalistes et le fait de vivre
bien sûr je pense que vous savez le 11
septembre il ya quelque chose qui s'est
terminée et quelque chose qui a commencé
et nous ne savons pas exactement quoi
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya toute la poésie
l'histoire qui est tombée en arrière je
pense qui s'est passé
ou alors est ce qui est arrivé on sait
ce qu est terminée mais c'est comme
c'est comme la déclaration de guerre de
c'est comme pearl harbour c'est comme la
chute du mur de berlin il ya un mot qui
commence
wahlberg est un mot là tu jouerais c'est
que je suis ardemment contre le
terrorisme intégriste et je ne mélange
pas l'islam et le terrorisme sont
heureux de l'entendre dire six comédiens
déjà je suis heureux de l'entendre
la vie en commençant des émissions tout
à l'heure avec filles et jamel est la
pire chose qu'on pourrait faire c'est de
jeter l'islam dans les bras du
fondamentalisme il faut faire le
contraire voilà il faut isoler les
terroristes et les toros peut venir de
partout
vous savez que il ya eu un terroriste
qui s'appelle ah bah oui
abbas georges habache le web apache
était chrétien alors il faut isoler les
terroristes et tâcher de regagner tout
tout tout tout tout ceux qui sont contre
les formes et il faudrait pas on peut
dire la télévision il faudrait pas qu'en
france ce soit le début d'un racisme
anti arabe parce que encore une fois ça
serait ce qui pourrait arriver de dieu
nous en garde
je te jure ce qui me fait le plus mal au
coeur et qui m'a le plus moi de toucher
ce qui me fait le plus peur pour
l'avenir c'est l'amalgamme que caen
risque de faire dans les rues je sais
que que ça va que l'enfer commence pour
nous vraiment j'ai ce sentiment là j'ai
peur pour ma petite soeur c'est pour ça
que jean d'ormesson du savès et le défi
la démocratie la démocratie ne peut pas
employer elle même les méthodes kelkoul
oui absolument pas
et donc il faut que la démocratie soit à
la fois forte et respectueuse des autres
alors vous êtes académicien français